firefighters are struggling to control
record-breaking wildfires
in 14 states the dixie fire the largest
in california destroyed almost all of
the historic gold rush town
of greenville that's about 50 miles away
from the town of paradise
which is still recovering after it was
devastated by the deadly campfire in
2018.
a new cbsn documentary bring your own
brigade follow survivors of that fire
and first responders who battle the
blaze the movie also focuses
on the global wildfire crisis
climate change in a lot of ways is a
distraction from the issue of fire
because
paradise was going to burn whether there
was climate change or not
even if climate change miraculously
went back to the 1960s level we would
still have a fire crisis
climate change is undoubtedly
aggravating fire problems
it's a major factor it's a performance
enhancer
but it is not the only thing if you say
climate change is the only thing that
matters
then the only thing to fix it is fixing
climate change that's not going to
happen for a long time
we asked director lucy walker about a
response to the crisis that inspired the
name of this documentary
bring your own brigade so as we continue
to see
to see worsening wildfires out west a
growing number of wealthy people
are hiring their own teams of private
firefighters to protect themselves
um talk to us about that because people
may not be aware
what the title means and what's actually
happening out there
that's right in the movie we have a
little piece of kim kardashian and her
and kanye's house
was saved by their private firefighters
and it kind of comes up in the film that
you know how do we feel about this that
the people who can afford to have their
own firefighters are going to be the
people that can
keep their homes and keep living in
these stunningly beautiful places
but that burn all the time and i think
the title also refers to
more than just that it refers also to
this
idea of you know are we on our own or
are we going to come together
as a community to tackle these bigger
problems because
a problem like the wildfires a little
bit like climate change
or the pandemic we're seeing it's it's
not something that we can
solve individually without coming
together and you kind of see this
dramatically play out during the film
you can watch bring your own brigade and
select theaters today you can also
stream it on the cbs news app and
paramount plus starting august 20th
paramount plus of course is the vision
of viacom cbs it's an incredible
documentary
really really well done